on
and a foul call on Richardson Ginny got
up and looked to go after him now
Richardson saying something back
did he pointing at him he thought he got
hit below the belt I think the officials
are going to look at it and definitely
going to take a look at it
some of the players trying to calm
people down
very good he's still doing the pointing
at Richardson who's saying come on come
on
let's take a peek
[Applause]
and he did he go down and right away
went up Mr criteria for a flagrant foul
you need a different angle to be able to
see it
let's see this one
and he threw a little forearm shooter at
him
[Applause]
and where it was placed is why it's
going to be a flavor